MARK MIRCHANDANI:
What's up, everyone?
Thanks for checking out "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Many teams are looking
at Kubernetes and Istio
to help manage their
complex applications.
But they still
come up short when
they're trying to implement and
host the actual infrastructure.
At Google Cloud
Next 2018, we first
introduced the simple
but radical idea
of a less disruptive
and more compliant
Services Platform built
entirely on open APIs.
We couldn't be more
proud to announce
that Google Cloud
Services Platform is
open to everyone in beta.
If you're currently using
Kubernetes or running a hybrid
of on-prem and in
the cloud, you now
have a powerful
tool to modernize
existing apps at your own pace.
Google Kubernetes Engine is
the industry-leading managed
Kubernetes service, letting
you focus on your application
and configuration
without worrying
about the operational
security or infrastructure.
GKE On-Prem brings that same
managed Kubernetes experience
to your on-prem clusters.
With Cloud Services
Platform, you
can write once and have
consistent environments,
plus a single source of truth
for configuration management.
There is a lot to take
of advantage here.
So check out the
beta and see how
CSP can help your architecture.
Speaking of modernizing
your applications,
if you've got some Java
applications lying around,
and you want to look
at containerization,
you'll really like
the cut of our Jib.
That is, Google's
open source Jib
project that helps build Java
applications into containers.
You can easily integrate
with Maven, Gradle,
or by using the
library directly.
Jib was just pushed
to version 1.0
and is now production ready.
So get building.
Even still, migrating
applications
can be a ton of work.
Last year, Google announced
that we're teaming up
with Velostrata to help
people make that migration
process a lot easier.
And now we're looking to team
up with illuma, experts in data
migration and integration.
So if you need some support
in migrating to the cloud,
or just want to build
a data pipeline,
Google and illuma
have your back.
So we've been talking a lot
about Google Cloud Next and all
the cool things that are
going to be shown off there.
But here's one more cool thing.
You can get a free
ticket to Next.
Google has released some new
certifications and Qwiklabs
content to go along with those.
Not only can you get one
month free of Qwiklabs
and get your hands-on
training, but you'll then
receive a discount for
the certification exam.
Then if you get
certified by March 31,
you'll get a free pass to Next.
There's no reason to delay.
So get started now and
unlock your cloud potential.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.